2584 شخص انهو حياتهم عن عمد في مصر عام
2021 ودي الارقام المبلغ عنها فقط
احدى الجامعات الحكوميه المصريه لقيو ان
طلاب الطب في السنه الاولى
64% منهم بيعانوا من الاكتئاب 78 واربعه
من عشره في الميه منهم بيعانوا من القلق
اما 58% منهم بيعانوا من اعرف طالبه
شديده التفاوض مرغوبه جدا في الرسم
والكتابه
ومن كلامها ان الرسم والكتابه انقذوها في
وقت كانت بتمر فيه بمشاعر مش لطيفه
فجاه الصيف اللي فات فقدت 15 كيلو من
وزنها فجاه مش عايزه تنزل الجامعه
مش حابه ترجع ترسم تاني مش حابه تكتب تاني
اهلها قلقانين جدا كشوفات اشاعات في بساط
طحنين وما فيش سبب عضوي خالص بيقول هو ده
حاصلني
البنت كانت من الوعي بكفايه ان هي تعرف ان
اللي هي حاسه به ممكن يكون علامه ان هي
بتمر بالم نفسي او مشكله نفسيه مات وبعدها
راحت في العلاج النفسي
وسط الاحصائيات اللي بنسمع عنها دي كلها
نعرف ازاي لو حد قريب مننا او عزيز علينا
بيمر ان الم نفسي او مشكله نفسيه
لما الحاجات اللي بيحبوا يعملوها كانت
متعودين عليها وما بيفوتوهاش خالص بطلوا
يعملوها فجاه كلنا عندنا صاحب ما بيفوتش
ماتش بلاي ستيشن ما بيفوتش ماتش كوره لو
ده اتغير فجاه ممكن دي تبقى علامه
لو البوستات على الفيسبوك او السوشيال
ميديا بدات تبقى حزينه او متلخبطه
احيانا ممكن يكتمل زي وصفات وداعه واحنا
ما بناخدش بالنا منها قوي بناخد بالنا بس
بعد فوات الاوان
لما عادات الاكل والنوم بتاعتهم وتتغير
لما يعطلوا في الدراسه في الشغل عن غير
عاداتهم
لما يحسوا بحزن ويبطلوا يتكلموا
لما حد قريب مننا بيبقى بيعاني من ازمه
نفسيه او الم نفسي احنا فعلا بنبقى عايزين
نساعده
بس ساعات بيطلع مننا بحسن نيه ومن غير ما
بقصد ردود افعال ممكن ما تكونش احسن حاجه
واحيانا نتيجتها بتبقى عكسيه او سلبيه
يعني ممكن تلاقينا بنقول بحسن نيه
يا ابني العياط ده الستات بطل بقى خليك
صلي ركعتين وهتبقى كويس
غرزه
عارف قانون الجذب قانون الجذب لما تفكر
ايجابي فتحس ايجابي فتصرف ايجابي عارف
قانون الجذب ده فعلوا حياتك هتتغير قوم
كده واتنطط انزل العب معنا انزل كل ده
هيتغير
طب ليه رسم ان احنا تحسن نيه بنبقى فعلا
عايزين نساعد الاشخاص دي بس وجود افعالنا
ما بتكونش هي الحل
لانه هم فعلا حفره وازمه مشكله نفسيه ولما
بيعمل النصائح اللي بتعملها له وبتطلبها
منه وبيحاول يعملها وما بتجيبش فايده بيحس
بالذنب او بالعدس او بيحسوا قليل
هو انا مقصر في ايه
فالذنب زاد مشكله تتفاقها واكتر واكتر
واكتر بس انا كان في نيتي يا سعد للاسف ده
ما حصلش
عمرك فكرت لو مريض عنده سكر ونسبه السكر
في الدم عاليه
محتاج يزبط جرعه الانسولين واكل وكده امك
فكرت ان لو حد قال له
الدنيا هتبقى احسن
عندي طلبه في الجامعه من ثلاث اسابيع كان
امتحانات المتر
لهم صديق في الدفعه جدو اتوفى وجدو ده هو
اللي مربيه
الولد بعد وفاه مش عايز يتكلم نهائيا كل
اللي بيعملوه ان هو بيتواصل بالكتابه او
بيشاور عياط مستمر مش عايز ينزل الجامعه
واهله قلقانين طبعا على الامتحانات زي
طبيعه كل الاهاني
الولاد كلموني وقالوا لي احنا عايزينه
يروح لحد متخصص نعمل ايه
وفعلا
راحوا
واقنعوا ان هم يودوه لحد متخصص
تفتكروا ليه كان رد فعلهم كده
ليه يتصرفوا كده ليه رد فعلهم ما كانش زي
المعتاد
الولاد دي عندها حاجه تبديه ولاد دي
بطارياتها مشكونه واللي بطاريته مشحونه
فعلا بيعرف يمضي الولاد دي واخده بالها من
نفسها
عمرك فكرت كده لما بطاريت عربيتك وانت
مسافر تبوظ او تنامي هو بيقومها غير عن
بطاريه عربيه مشفونه هم الولاد دول كانوا
كده برضو
واخدين بالهم من نفسه وبطرياتهم ومشحونه
وتتركهم ايه ده يعني هو اصلا في اليوم
بتاعنا اللي بنصحى فيه من الساعه سبعه الا
ربع الصبح ونجري عشان نلحق اول محاضره ومن
اول محاضره على اول
اصلا ما اكلتش اي حاجه فلازم اجري عشان
الحق بعد كده اخلص اليوم بتاعي على الساعه
خمسه من الساعه خمسه جري على الجيم عشان
اعمل فوق بقى
وجمال وبعدين خلصت روحت الساعه ثمانيه
لازم اخدكوش اونلاين عشان السيزينه ما
ينفعش يبقى فاضي كده وبعدين ده انا عندي
زمايلي طلبه في الدفعه بينشروا ابحاث وهم
طلبه لسه انت مش عايزاني ابقى زيهم ولا
ايه هاعمل كل ده واخلي بالي من نفسي في كل
ده
ولا ما شاء الله احنا بقى في نهايه السنه
وديسمبر انتم عارفين تقفيله السنه اللي
على السوشيال ميديا كلمونا عن انجازاتنا
في عام 2022 قريت كم كتاب انا قفلت 300
كتاب متقفلت لا كسلان وما لكش عذر مش عارف
مش لاقي وقت تقرا في اوديو بوكس ينفع
تقراه وانت ماشي
يجي الصيف بقى
يولع بالصيف ان هو اصلا تمن شهور في مصر
والناس ما بتجيش من الساحل في الثمان شهور
دول انت يا عيني شاليان من ثمانيه لثمانيه
وهما في الساحل انا ما اعرفش بيجوا امتى
وبيشتغلوا امتى
وبعدين هم طول الوقت بياخدوا تاني احنا
برضو بناخد تاني بس التام بتاعنا واحنا
بننقل من شغلنا نقول ان الشغلانه التانيه
يعني رايح في السكه فالشمس انتم عارفين
بتعمل فينا ايه يعني
من نفسي في كل ده سوبر مان بقى الفظيع اخد
بالي من نفسي امتى ان شاء الله يعني ايه
القصه
انا ما اعرفش اخد بالي من نفسي غير ان
ماما بتقولها لي وانا نازل الصبح حبيبي خد
بالك من نفسك خد جاكيت الجو برد
اخلي بالي من نفسي او راعيها
ان اعمل حاجات معينه
في يومي بشكل مختلف الحاجات دي على فكره
يعني من اول ما بصحى لغايه ما انام بعملها
بشكل مختلف عشان تحسسني بالتجديد بالنشاط
عشان ده طريقتي تفضل مشحونه وما بحسش ان
انا وقعت
ايه الحاجات دي هقول لكم عليها بس في شرط
لاي حاجه بعملها في نومي عشان الحاجه اللي
بعملها فحسسني بالنشاط وبالتجديد اني
اعملها بحضور وبوعي برضو كلام بقى بتاع
علم النفس المتخصص ده يعني ايه في دوره
وعي
ده الحضور
اني ابقى بعمل اي حاجه وانا مركز في
اللحظه اللي انا فيها هنا ودلوقتي بس مش
قلقان على المواصلات اللي لسه هروح بعد
ساعتين فشغله دماغي وانا الحاجات اللي
حصلت قديمه يمكن حتى من ساعه فاتت
بس ده كلام برضو صعب اعملها ازاي وهنا
ودلوقتي وابقى حاضر والكلام ده
ببساطه شديده فعل حواستك الخمسه في اي
حاجه بتعملها احنا كلنا بنصحى الصبح عشان
فنجان القهوه بتاعنا بيبقى الفنجان في
ايدك الكوتش بايده وبجري مش عارف عارفين
المنظر ده ده اللي احنا بنعمله طبيعي في
اليوم بتاعنا كل حاجه بنعملها وانا مش
حاسس بها ومش مستطعمها فعادي لو عملت اي
حاجه في روتين يومك
بحضور في رند ناو حققت اول شرط
تاني شرط انك تبقى وانت مفعل خاصك الخمسه
تبقى واعي واعي ان ايه
وعين مشاعري
وعين تصرفاتي واري الافكار
كده كل نشاط الانشطه اللي هقولها لكم
دلوقتي لو عملناها حقيقي هتبقى مختلفه
الصيف ده كنت مسافره في رحله
واللي طلع هايكنج عارف ان هي تجربه شويه
شديده بالذات في الصيف قاسيه قوي كنا
بنهايط مثلا
تسعه ساعات الجو حر جدا احنا عايشين بقى
بزق في رجلينا مش قادرين اصلا وعمالين
نقول الدانيل البدوي فاضل قد ايه واحنا
معنا واحد مختلف جدا
فجاه نلاقيه بيقول لنا شايفين الصفراء
اللي هناك دي شكلها عامل ازاي ده التكوين
الصخري بتاعها لو ركزي شكلها تحسي كانها
نمر وبعدين ينادي علينا واحنا في عز التعب
وقولي تعالي بصي شمي ريحه الزعتر البري
ولا الحبق
الراجل ده كان ماشي في الهايكنج فعلا مش
برجليه بحواسطه الخمسه موجود بحواسه
الخمسه الراجل ده كان حاضر في اللحظه اللي
بيعمل
تعالوا نتكلم على الانشطه اللي لو عملناها
يبقى براعي نفسي فيها او براعي زيتي
اول نوع من الانشطه دي هي انشطه خاصه
بمشاعرنا
نعمل ايه عشان نراعي نفسنا على مستوى
المشاعر
ان يبقى عندي دايره من ناس بحبها
وتبقى موجوده معي في اوقات الفرح والحزن
اعرف اعبر عن مشاعري معهم دي انا براعي
نفسي وبراعي مشاعري فيها بس احيانا ما
ببقاش عايزه اتكلم حتى لو الدايره دي
موجوده ساعات ببقى مش عايز ومش قادر وانا
عارف ان حوالي ناس بحبهم وواثق بحبهم بجد
اعمل ايه في الوقت ده
ينفع تعبر عن مشاعرك حتى لو مش قادر ينفع
تكتب ندون مشاعرنا او تسجلها بصوت دي من
الطرق فعلا اللي بتخليك تعبر عن مشاعرك
ومهما كنت حاسس بحمل بس مش قادر تعبر عبر
لنفسك لغايه ما تبقى حاسس انك قادر تكلم
حد
برضو ممكن اراعي مشاعري بحاجه تانيه
اني اعرف اقول لا طبعا احنا متربيين ان لا
ما ينفعش عيب تعالي على نفسك بقى والحاجات
لخبطونا بين ان احنا نساعد يبقى عندنا
ايثار بان انا اجي على نفسي انا كده باجي
على نفسي عمرك فكرت ان الطلب ان الطلب منك
ده مش مناسب لك بقيمك لمبادئك الاحتياجاتك
انت مش قادر تعمله وضفت عليك اصلا
محتاجين نتعلم عشان نراعي نفسنا على مستوى
مشاعرنا نقول لا بس من غير عدوانيه عشان
ساعات واحنا لسه بنتعلم ونقول لا بنعملها
بعدوانيه شديده
من غير احساس بالذنب تاني نوع من الانشطه
في رعايه الذات بعد الانشطه الخاصه
بالمشاعر انشطه روحانيه
ايا كانت ديانه اي حد فينا
الشعائر الدينيه لما بنعملها بوعي وحضور
وتركيز والتحاضر ومستشعر كل حاجه بعملها
انا كده براعي نفسي على مستوى المشاعر
كمان علاقتي بالطبيعه حد فيكم فاكر اخر
مره اسافر مثلا البحر وشم ريحه اليود وهو
داخل المدينه لسه كده
او هو واقف على اتشط ورجليه وصوابع رجليه
دايسه في الرمله الناعمه السخنه بتحسه ده
ولا انا موجوده وخلاص اتحسبت علي سفريه
وخلاص
اخر نوع من الانشطه
انشطه عقليه
ان ادي لنفسي فرصه اني اتعلم
واتعلم حاجه جديده مهما كبرت ينفع يبقى
عندك اربعين خمسه واربعين سنه وفيه حاجات
نفسك تعملها نفسك تركب عجل نفسك تتعلم
سباحه بس الناس حواليك هيقولوا لك بعد ما
شاب ودوا الكتاب
ادي لنفسك الفرصه انك تتعلم
واعملها وانت مصدق انك تستاهل ده وتستحق
ده
كده انت مراعي نفسك على المستوى العقلي
كمان انك تفهم نفسك ومشاعرك وافكارك
وتصرفاتك
عمركم مثلا في موقف من المواقف ان فعلته
وبعدين قلته ايه ده الموقف ما كانش يستاهل
رد الفعل ده وانا عملت كده ليه وانا
انفعلت كده ليه
عمرك فكرت ان ممكن تكون منفعل عشان حاجه
مالهاش علاقه اصلا
ان ننطق ممكن يكون نكش جواك حاجه قديمه
انت مش فاكرها مش عارفها بس انا عشان
متلهوب وبجري مش واخد وقت ان انا افهم
نفسي ممكن اكون الشخص ان فعلت عليه خالص
فكرني بحاجه قديمه او فتح جوايا حته انا
مش واعيناه
ده ان انا اراعي نفسي على المستوى العقلي
طيب انت عايزه تقولي لي ان انا هعمل كل
الحاجات دي
والانشطه دي
الانشطه دي فرديه وانشخص ومش محتاج تعمل
حاجه جديده انت اصلا في يومك بتشرب قهوتك
بتصلي العادي بتاعك اعمله بوعي
الستات بقى عارفين ان في حاجات كده يا
عيني اول ما يسمعوا كلمه راعي نفسك خلي
بالك من نفسك
بقى انت نور والصبح هحط لها
لازم يبقى التركيز من العشره
بنسمع كده
وانا براعي نفسي باخد بالي من نفسي وعنده
وقت بتاعي اخلي بالي
ان في ناس في دايرتي من حقهم يعرفوا انا
بعمل ده ليه لو عندي ابن اقول له انا بعمل
ده انا بحب الوقت ده ده وقت المسلسل بتاعي
بعد ما بخلص واجباتي وحاجتي لان احيانا
الناس بتتلخبط بين الواجب والحق
فيبقى في لخبطه فتلاقيني الدنيا تضرب تقلب
وورايا بكميه مهام فظيع بس انا
ما بتمشيش كده خالص لو براعي نفسي بجد
ببقى عارف ان ده من حقي وفي نفس الوقت
واخد بالي من واجباتي ومن الناس اللي في
دايرتي
هنعمل تمارين بسيط دلوقتي
هطلب منكم كلكم تغمضوا عينيكم
تفضلوا مغمضين هسالكم شويه اسئله وانت
مغمضين لو الاجابه ومنطبقه عليكم ترفعوا
في بعض اكتر من اجابه وطبقه علينا صباعين
واحنا مغمضين عينينا عادي جدا مكملين
يلا بينا
غمضين عينينا في ناس لسه مفتحه شايفاهم
عمرك حسيت ان مش من حقك تريح
عشان لو ريحت هتقع من السباق وهتبقى مذنب
ومقصر
عمرك حسيت مهما نجحت وعملت انجازات
القارن بغيرك
عمرك الناس قالوا لك انت ازاي ناجح وهو
كده وانت من جواك تقول وانا حاسس اي حاجه
ان بيقولوه ده بيتكلموا عن حد تاني ده مش
انا
عمرك حسيت انك شايل هم كبير على صدرك مش
لاقي حدوته
عمرك حسيت ان انت
عملت تشتغل وتنجز وتحقق انا ترس في
الساقيه
ونفتح عينينا ونبص حوالينا
بالظبط تقريبا كلنا مرينا بالمشاعم دي
ما فيش حد فينا معش ده
وعشان احنا مش لوحدنا وعشان حياتنا تكون
لنا بلا استثناء غاليه وعشان بجد فيه طول
الوقت حد عايز يساعدنا احنا بس اللي
محتاجينه نتكلم عشان حياتكم غاليه علينا
شكرا
[تصفيق]